from the very beginning i got an email
from someone
that knows the cuomo family very well uh
that said to me
you know i'm sorry for your loss
something we never heard from the
governor by the way
i'm sorry for your loss your fight is a
valiant one but watch
your back
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the senior meteorologist at fox news
author of the new book make your own
sunshine inspiring stories of people who
find light in dark times
and a woman who is not a big fan of new
york governor andrew cuomo
janice dean finally welcome to the
reuben report
oh my gosh thank you for having me my
friend how'd you like that little
addition that i
gave to your bio there did that does
that feel right to you
you know i gotta tell you if you told me
a year ago that i would be in the middle
of a
storm involving the governor of new york
i would have said what are you drinking
and where can i get some well you
you certainly are and you know my
audience knows i try to do these
interviews
really as free form as possible but i
thought with this
interview i'm going to do it a little
more intentionally because the book
which i've been reading over the last
couple of days it's it's so light
and warm and decent and it puts a smile
on your face
but this last year you really have
stepped into a fight that
that so many of us are dealing with at
so many different levels
so for people that have no idea about
what
has gone on in your life in the past
year can you just lay it out how did how
did this all start and when did you
decide to really get into the public
fight
march 25th was the order which governor
cuomo
put his signature on that allowed covet
positive patience into nursing homes 9
000 of them and that was a fairly recent
development
the reason why i'm so interested in this
topic is because we lost
my husband's parents in separate elder
care facilities in late march we lost
his dad
and in april about two weeks later we
lost his mother
and obviously tragic i never planned to
be someone who
is a spokesperson on behalf of uh
you know my husband's parents and
thousands of others that we lost
but i felt like i had to because when i
saw the governor
on television programs like his brothers
on cnn
joking around and not even approaching
the nursing home
issue that's when i decided to get a
little bit angry
because i felt like my husband's parents
in the situation that they were
presented with
unknowingly was not being represented
fairly in the mainstream media and
you know going back to his parents we
didn't even know
there was a march 25th order and the
plan was we were supposed to have both
of them and
an assisted living residence close to us
on long island
i feel you know a kindred spirits with
people who have to talk about what to do
with their aging parents
their health was failing them they lived
in a four-story walk-up in brooklyn for
50 years we had
many conversations about getting them
out of there because they were going to
have
issues trying to go up and down the
stairs so for many years the
conversation was there we wanted to get
them into a different place we offered
to help them
monetarily and they just never wanted to
take that they just said we're just
going to stick it out we love it here
and we'll deal with it as it comes and
as it happened his dad got dementia his
health was failing him
his mom was very spry for you know a 75
76 year old but she had back problems
she had problems walking
and so it got to the point where we had
aids going to visit them
that wasn't working out so we took his
mom
to look at assisted facilities uh
and she loved the one close to us on
long island she
signed the paperwork his father was in
bad health so we had to get him in
better shape before he could he could
join her in the assisted living
residence
um and that's when cove it happened i
mean we hadn't even cleared out their
apartment
the we were still plant paying the rent
for them so it was very recent
that we had put them in the in the elder
care facilities they had never been
separated in their lives
and we were just hoping to get mickey
his father in better shape so
cobit happened we were in quarantine in
early march
we weren't able to see them we were
getting updates
from their separate elder care
facilities sean was able to talk to his
mom every day
um because she was you know she was
lucid his dad
obviously was tough because he had
dementia we got a call
on a saturday morning in late march not
even knowing he was
ill and they said that mickey was
not feeling well he was running a fever
and so of course we were concerned
and we were talking about what we were
going to do and three hours later we get
a call
saying he was dead we had no idea
he had died of covet until we saw the
death certificate
and sean had to deliver the news to his
mother
and to say that she was heartbroken is
an understatement
she got sick in her assisted living
facility
was diagnosed with covid when they
brought her to the hospital and she died
in the hospital several days later
the last thing she asked my husband to
do was put her name on the easter gifts
for the kids
[Music]
so i never wanted to tell their story my
husband is a very private person
he's not on tv he's not a broadcaster
he's a
firefighter 25 years in the department
his dad was a firefighter as well
but when i wasn't seeing the coverage
of the nursing home issue and the fact
that i was finding out that cuomo wasn't
counting those that died in the hospital
like my mother-in-law
that's when i decided it was time to
tell my story our story
so that at least somebody anybody
would you know find out that this was
actually something that was happening in
new york
yeah boy all right there's there's so
many sort of offshoots where we go there
first off i have to say i don't know if
you know this but i'm actually from long
island as well and i know a lot of long
island firefighters so i have no doubt
that sean is a great guy because every
single one of them that i know
are are great people um well i guess
first
just for a little more on on the
timeline so how how long was it that
your folks didn't see each other
or your your in-laws didn't see each
other before you got that call
about your father-in-law well you know
it started out that both mickey and dee
were in the nursing home together uh but
his mother was in better shape so that's
when she went to the assisted living
residence and i would say they were
probably apart for
a few weeks so they were
you know they were apart for a few weeks
but they they knew that they would be
together at some point at the assisted
living residence
um so you know it it wasn't very long
uh that cove had happened um when they
were you know
when they were in this situation do you
remember
when cuomo signed that piece of
legislation or whatever it was do you
remember thinking
uh oh this could be a problem there were
so many things happening at once it was
almost like impossible to make sense of
any of it back then i know it's hard to
remember
just a year ago we didn't know about it
dave
i mean honestly i found out about it
after they had died
no one told us about it you know i
remember the red flag
after the fact was that we got a call
about mickey
uh i would say about a week before he
passed away
saying that they were going to move to
him to another floor because they were
going to allow for more
people to come into the residence but
they didn't say infected patients
and we had no idea we only learned
after they had died that there was a
mandate in place to put covet positive
patients
so you know that's a big deal i think
whose responsibility would that have
been
the nursing home the assisted living
residents someone should have told us
but the other point of that is that we
weren't able to see them
you know we were in quarantine sean did
see his mom
before she got sick he dropped off
flowers and a card
after his dad had passed away and he was
able to see her
six feet away with a mask on but he
wasn't able to go and hug her
you know so there were all these things
in place where we physically couldn't do
anything we were all
you know you were you're almost jailed
you know you couldn't move you couldn't
find things out you couldn't go see them
you couldn't bring them to you
you know obviously if i had known about
a march 25th order we would have done
things very differently we would have
found a way to bring them here
you know his sister-in-law would have
taken one of them we would have done
something
yeah look we all know hindsight is 20 20
but do you think in retrospect that the
nursing homes themselves
should have done different things should
have just protested the order
i mean do you think that they some of
them may have sort of known i know that
we have more info now so i know it's
tough to to do that kind of
quarterbacking
from what i know and the people that
i've talked with
that work in nursing homes they did not
want to take the covet-positive patients
they felt they had no
choice and if you read the order they
weren't allowed to even
test them they were prohibited from
testing them for covid
uh so you know you know that in itself
is is like if you couldn't test them
then you didn't know if they even had
the virus
so what could be the logic behind not
being allowed to test people that you're
bringing into the home
well this is a bigger broader subject
that i think we need to investigate
there are
several investigations into the nursing
home issue which i am grateful for
there's a federal one and there's an fbi
one
and what i want to know is first of all
the origins of the march 25th order
where did that come from because it's
not based on science we all knew that
putting
infected patients into where our most
vulnerable live
is not scientific it was going to spread
like wildfire which is what our governor
said as well
that it would be like wildfire through
dry grass
so i want to know where that order came
from there are reports out there
that the governor was not listening to
science he was listening to hospital
lobbyists
who were saying to him right we can't
take these
patients for very long you know they're
not maybe paying
customers we need to get them over to
some place else so that we can allow for
more people to come in
at the beginning of the pandemic he had
no idea we thought there was going to be
thousands upon thousands of people that
were going to come into the hospitals
and take over the beds
so i at the beginning i don't blame him
for not really knowing what to do and
sort of saying well maybe we should put
them
the back end but it was in place for 46
days
and then it was reversed and scrubbed
from the website
so that should also tell you something i
think there is
corruption involved i think there is a
criminal aspect to it i think it
involves hospital lobbyists
and the curious thing as well is that
cuomo put it in place
for a blanket immunity for all of the
nursing homes so that we could not sue
them
just a couple of days after that march
25th order wasn't was put into effect
have you talked to lawyers about how
that could possibly be legal because
when i was doing a little research that
seems
that seems crazy that the governor in
effect is allowed to say i'm going to
make a policy
and regardless of the results of the
policy i'm going to make sure
that the places that i'm forcing to do
something cannot be sued i mean i i
don't even see how that could be
remotely legal
well they're they're trying now in
albany to reverse that
uh that executive order so that the
nursing homes can be
held accountable listen it's not about
do you want them to be held accountable
i mean is that
i'll never get my i'll never get my
in-laws back right
and and and the the nursing homes i felt
like
they were just doing what they could
with the situation that they had
dave they were wearing garbage bags they
had no ppe
that's another separate issue is they
didn't have
the wherewithal to deal with all of
these patients that were coming in
and you listen they took good care of my
husband's parents you know before covent
so and we're not getting any answers
from them either i think they're afraid
i know that
the nursing home people the executives
and the and the folks that
work in the nursing homes they are
afraid to talk
they don't want to lose their jobs and i
do think that there needs to be more
whistleblowers and that's why i think
there needs to be a real investigation
with subpoena power
so people in the nursing home industry
and the hospital industry
those that really want to tell the truth
can come forward with that without
thinking that they're going to lose
their livelihoods so
when did you decide to really go public
about this because as you said
your husband's a private person and
although you're a public person
you know it's it's his parents they're
they're your in-laws it's not something
that it would be that comfortable
talking about probably because it's
deeply personal all that kind of stuff
well when i started to see the
information about the
the march 25th order and then i started
to see the information
um the daily caller was the one that put
out
a report saying that cuomo wasn't
counting those that died in the hospital
and i thought that that was bizarre
because it's like if there's a car crash
on the highway
and the person doesn't unfortunate you
know tragically
die on the highway but they're
transported to the hospital
does that mean that's a hospital death
no of course not right
it's still a car crash that happened on
the highway
so that that to me was curious
and i started seeing the governor going
on all of these television programs
and talking about you know how great his
leadership
was new york tough you know bending that
curve he was selling a poster he was
selling a poster
um showing that that bend of the curve
which was like a mountain and and hal
had all the covet cases and i thought to
myself how gross
that he's using covet cases my husband's
parents are on that curve that he
supposedly
crushed and then on the poster there was
all these like little pictures of the
things that he loved about himself like
his
his dog and and a giant q-tip
because of the you know the the show
that he was putting on with his
brother chris cuomo on television that
was the breaking point for me
i was thinking about writing an op ad
about the situation
because it was i thought i wanted to
tell my family story to bring awareness
but when i saw cuomo on with his brother
joking around like who's the who's the
favorite son
and love gov and the big giant q-tip
i lost my mind i just thought to myself
this is what kind of universe am i
living in with
thousands upon thousands of dead the
body bags are piling up outside of
nursing homes
we weren't able to have wakes or
funerals we were
we luckily we knew someone who owned a
funeral home
uh who went to school with my
sister-in-law that helped us
bury them um so
that's when i decided to talk to my
friend tucker carlson i was telling him
what was going on with the nursing homes
and
and my concerns with what was happening
in new york
and he told me he said you have an
invitation to come on my show if you
ever want to tell a story
and so it was that day after i saw the
cuomo brothers comedy hour that i went
on tucker's show
that i mean okay so everyone remembers
that interview with
with chris and and governor cuomo and
you know the laughing and all that
so i'm going to jump forward for just a
second but when when you saw chris
because i'm sure you saw it a few weeks
ago
say that he can no longer talk about his
brother on the show
because it's personal i mean that's like
basically
vomit-inducing stuff like we can give
him the worst sort of fluff interviews
we can both sit there with our fake tans
and laugh hysterically and have everyone
write fluff pieces
about the sexy cuomo brothers or
whatever it is that they're doing on
huffpo
and then and now oh now he's in a little
hot water
wouldn't be wouldn't be journalistic if
i talked about him now
right can you imagine if that happened
on fox news
yeah exactly right so i don't even think
chris cuomo should be on television
right now uh he
it's not ethical i mean cuomo is a huge
story right i mean
the guy could be impeached there are
there are um
you know motions going forward that
could he could be impeached we have me
too
involved now with eight women um he
doesn't even do
like a news segment uh you know he just
continues to do his show ignoring the
huge elephant in the room
um so yeah it's quite rich for him to
say that he can no longer interview his
brother
yeah so so then then the story blows up
and now you now
you sort of became the center of this
thing for a couple weeks it was like oh
the nursing home thing people couldn't
believe it
you're right in the center of it um
since i spent so much time on this show
talking about cancel culture and dealing
with the mob and everything else can you
just talk about a little bit about like
the love and i'm guessing some of the
hate that you've received in the midst
of all this
from the very beginning i got an email
from someone
that knows the cuomo family very well uh
that
said to me you know i'm sorry for your
loss something we never heard from the
governor by the way
i'm sorry for your loss your fight is a
valiant one but
watch your back i knew that
early on that i was in for the fight and
i had heard that he was vindictive i
also heard
that he was a bully um you know there
were many times that i would do
interviews and they would always ask the
governor's office to make a comment
and uh twice the governor's office said
well
you know can you ask jen first of all
they never said we're really sorry for
your loss
um it was always um can you ask janice
the exact uh day her in-laws died and
what nursing homes they were at
so that twice the governor's office
asked that
um and then there was one time there was
a daily mail article that was put out
and they asked for a comment
and the quote was she's not a reliable
source on anything except the weather
so you know and and i just thought to
myself well
you know that's not very creative yeah
um but certainly on social media in the
early days of this
i i was you know i was definitely
attacked
um he was the most powerful guy i mean
they were talking about him being a
president
um he was you know the fact that he was
writing a book in the middle of a
pandemic and then again
uh being on television celebrating
himself winning an emmy award
and he had all these celebrities that
were were appearing with him
at his press conferences
i actually got into a little bit of a
twitter spat with ben stiller because he
was doing a uh
a birthday celebration with whoopi
goldberg by the way they were raising
money for cuomo
how much was it for for a virtual event
it was like 20 grand a plate for a
virtual event in the midst of all of
this something
right it was it was at least a thousand
dollars for the bare minimum yeah
um so i just thought listen i'm gonna
i'm gonna let ben stiller know what
happened to the nursing homes in new
york he's a
he's a new yorker um and he came back at
me pretty quickly and was just like well
i like the governor it's too bad that
you don't like him and you know
uh it was just so dismissive and uh
it didn't take long for ben stiller to
realize you know
what my family had been through and to
his
credit which is more than most people do
he apologized and he deleted his tweet
and and i actually said i'm okay with
that you know
he didn't know my family story now he
does
maybe he's more educated on the
situation and that's my
whole thing is if one person can be
educated by me
telling my story about what's happening
in new york
then all of that is worthwhile so what
do you make of sort of where
cuomo is at right now because
you know now he's got as you said
there's at least eight women accusing
him of some level of sexual impropriety
i mean i've said this a million times
before it's like okay an accusation is
one thing but of course you need
you need proof you need corroboration
but that's not the rules
that his team have been playing by for
quite some time those weren't the rules
with brett kavanaugh or a litany
of other people on the right so this is
sort of
of his making just where do you sense
he's
at right now between that and and of
course all of this
well he's not going to leave he's
already said that
um and there is you know i think it's
kind of a sham
they say that they've started the
proceedings for
impeachment in new york but it's going
to take not weeks but
months and then they're done in june so
i don't think that's going to happen
i am relying on the law uh you know the
investigations that are going on right
now the federal investigation the fbi
investigation there was also a doj
investigation
uh you know under bar that i hope
continues under biden
um the the me too stuff um at first i
was
a little bit shocked by it but now that
i think of the person that we're talking
about you know
sexual harassment is not about sex it's
about power
and so his whole mo is about i'm the
most powerful guy and i can do whatever
i want so now it doesn't surprise me
that he treated women badly and
he's treated other people badly you know
his co-workers
ron kim who is a friend of mine he is a
democrat
uh he had an uncle that died in a
nursing home
he's been very vocal about the nursing
home situation i am grateful
for him because he is raising awareness
on his side of the aisle of the
situation
and he al he also came out with his um
experience with the governor calling him
on a weekend
yelling at him uh and saying you know i
i'm gonna
i'm gonna ruin you essentially if you if
you go against me
um so i just i hope and pray dave
that the law helps us out here and
that they get to the bottom and he you
know the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth
i've always said the only thing i want
right now is a bipartisan investigation
with subpoena power
that puts the governor on the stand so
to speak
his health commissioner howard zucker
and the people
that surrounded him that helped cover up
the numbers you know that's another
big story is the fact that it was the
a.g
the democratic a.g here in new york put
out her own report
saying that they purposely under-counted
uh the nursing home deaths those that
died in the hospital were never counted
i mean listen as a new yorker i know how
out of whack the the whole state
government is in new york and half the
people that were in it 10 years ago are
in jail right now it's it's all very
bizarre in new york
has this changed any of your political
beliefs as you've been in this fight
you know i've always said um i'm not a
political person i
never have been i'm originally from
canada you know
i was born i think there's a government
up there right you got a government that
guy with the fancy socks
yes the fancy socks guy um
you know my mom is more political than i
am uh you should meet her sometime
but you know i'm the meteorologist on
fox i've always said
the only red and blue that i see on the
map are areas of low pressure and
high pressure and i i stick with that
um i i like the fact that nobody knows
who i voted for when i got the job at
fox
it was never a prerequisite to tell them
who i voted for
so i will remain that way um
but i will tell you i've often said to
people
what if i worked for a different channel
and the governor that i was going after
was a republican what do you think
would happen and how much coverage do
you think my story would get
yeah i i get what you're dropping i get
what you're dropping
um all right well before we move on from
this
because i do want to talk about the book
of course i mean is there anything else
well actually wait i do have one other
thing for sure
which is that we actually delayed this
interview taping a few days because you
just got
the second covid shot and it sounds like
that thing really knocked you out huh
oh listen i am pro-vaccine i
i have um i have ms i was diagnosed with
multiple sclerosis
16 years ago so i'm a compromised person
um and so i believe in vaccinations and
i was always wanting to get one and uh
so my
neurologist wrote me a note and i was
you know i was
in line with the other comorbidities um
the first shot was fine you know i had
the pain in the arm
and then the second shot my husband also
had had the
the vaccinations as well and and he
didn't do too badly you know he
the for maybe 12 to 18 hours he was
fluish
and you know he had the aches and pains
but man
i you know for i would say for 48 hours
it was like i had covered and uh
i had the worst headache the headache
was so bad that i was
nauseous the whole time and um
you know i i couldn't see my children i
couldn't look at anything i couldn't see
the tv i was literally
in a dark room so you listen i'm
grateful i've come
out of it on the other side doing well
um and i
encourage everyone to get the vaccine i
believe in vaccinations
and i'm grateful for the scientists that
came up with them
um but yes i will warn those the second
vaccination can be a doozy
well that is the perfect segue because
you're saying all of that
while you're smiling and that really is
that really is the point of the book an
excellent product placement behind you
by the way
really really spot on um but one of the
things that i know
what oh well you know i've got people uh
but but one of the things that i really
loved about the book is when i
when i do my show every day i try
to do it with a little bit of a smile on
my face i try to do it so that people
don't feel depressed after about the
news
i'm not trying to just bludgeon
everybody so that they're stuck
watching which is pretty much what cnn
and a lot of the other places are doing
so i guess first how did you kind of
come to that place
where telling people some of the good
stuff actually mattered to you
i've been telling good news stories for
many years now i do a feature on fox
news radio
called the dean's list um and it's a
60-second feel-good story
about a person doing kind of things for
someone else
or you know doing something that brings
sunshine into someone's day
so i've been doing that for a very long
time and i always thought to myself i
would love to make this into a book
where i could dive into these stories
each make them a chapter so this was
that
this was that book i started working on
it before the pandemic
but i wrote most of it and did a lot of
the interviews during the pandemic
and more than ever even though we were
socially distancing from each other i
was finding these stories
all over the place of people doing
wonderful things
for other people we were adapting as
human beings
um you know you saw people doing car
parades for birthdays i got one of those
my husband did that for me for my 50th
birthday
um so and the other part of this was
you know i wanted to put this book out
in the universe for other people to read
to to show them that there are good
people doing kind things for others all
over the place it's what it what it's
what unites us you know i really think
that
kindness begets kindness and those that
do good things for others
it gets passed along right so but
what i didn't realize dave is that i was
the one that was going to get the most
out of writing this book because i was
talking to these wonderful people during
the darkest time for our family
and and getting light and goodness from
all of these stories and interviews that
i was doing and every day you know i
would i'd take my
oldest son matthew for a walk and that
would be our topic of conversation he'd
be like
mom who'd you talk to today tell me the
story and i would tell them the story of
the napkin notes dad who wrote napkin
notes for his daughter
emma when she was just a little girl and
how he continued
doing that even though he was diagnosed
with cancer and thought he might not
live to see her
graduate so he wanted to make sure he
wrote napkin notes
for hundreds of school days in case they
lost him
he's still here and i talked to him and
i talked to emma
and so those are the people that
brightened my day when we were going
through such
dark times uh so that's
the ironic part of this is i got so much
out of writing this book more that more
so than i ever thought i would
yeah so i want to dive into a couple of
stories because there's some really
great stuff in there but i'm curious
when you were
pitching the book and bringing it to
your publishers and everything is
is selling a book that's that's so
positive is that tough for those guys
because if you just look at a bookstore
you know
front front area what's in the window i
mean
it's all basically depressing stuff you
know the world's coming to end
the pandemic's gonna kill you trump
tried to kill you somebody else is
coming to get you you know blah blah
blah blah
it's a tough sell i'm not going to lie
and
what i didn't tell you is before the
dean's list happened i did a good news
story on fox news a show called
happening now with my friend jane
skinner
and she was the one that came up with
the dean's list because she thought you
know the news is so terrible we need
something bright and cheery and you do
the weather and
and you know the weather is is a lot of
times it's mostly sunny but sometimes
it's stormy but why don't we work on a
good news story that we can use as a
kicker we call it a kicker in the
business
and so we started doing that on
television
but the news kind of like took over and
the dean's list got killed more often
than not
but i was you know she was always a
cheerleader of it so the moral of the
story is
you know what sometimes the good news
doesn't sell
um but i think now more than ever
we need these stories dave you know i
really think that we need to hear these
hopeful
good stories about trying to be a better
human being
um and so that's my message and i will
tell you
that i got a lot of people saying to me
okay your book is coming out
when are you going to stop with the
cuomo stuff because we need the right
hi i'm the sunny girl who brought you
this the most make your own sunshine
stories
and i said you know what i'm both why
can't i be both because i
am both i'm still the half the glasses
half full i'm still the mostly sunny
girl
i'm also an advocate who wants to shine
sunlight as a disinfectant so
you know i think the advocacy can also
be making your own sunshine
um so you know trying to balance both of
those things is
i can be both at the same time but i'm
not gonna lie sometimes
the good news stories are a tough sell
excellent use of the metaphor with
sunshine as the best disinfectant that
fully works with the book um give me
give me like two stories that you
that really particularly moved you i can
pick one or two but
but if you got some that are right off
the top of your head well it's funny
because
everyone tells me a different story that
they love
and that's what i love about it is that
you know someone will say well
i loved you know the the carrie blasey
story so i'll tell you that one that was
the first one the first
um one of the first interviews that i
did during the pandemic and carrie and i
became very close friends
afterwards simple story her daughter
uh was diagnosed with type 1 diabetes
forgive me type 2 diabetes what's the
more serious one i
forgive me um i don't want to screw this
up
so i'm going to get my book right this
is this is impressive an author actually
going to the source
i like it well wait i've got let's see
who can find it first
i don't want to screw it up because
there's there's a really
okay there's a really there's two types
of diabetes
and the one that she has is the really
serious one type one
type one okay and that's why it's
important because
carrie is a big advocate for type one
diabetes because
that's you know not to say that type 2
is is not a serious illness as well
um but type 1 is when you're really
really
constantly concerned about your child
every day they take her
you know her measurements her glucose
levels she's got a special
you know uh a a special portal on her
body that has to be
you know her insulin has to be just
right the right level
so having said that um carrie put a sign
on her door
saying that she had a person who was
compromised living in her house and as a
person who lives with ms i can totally
identify with that
at the beginning of the pandemic we
didn't know how bad it was she didn't
want the virus anywhere near her
daughter her compromised daughter so she
put a sign on the door that said
if you have any deliveries leave the
package here don't ring my doorbell i'm
not opening up the door
just leave it here and i will sanitize
the package and bring it in
so a wonderful fedex driver sees the
sign
and and and says oh goes back to his
fedex truck
they see this by the way on a camera he
doesn't know that he's being filmed they
have one of those nest cameras on there
on their doorstep
he goes back to the fedex truck grabs uh
some wipes
and wipes the package he smudges the
print
on the package and and thinks to himself
oh i don't want them
to wonder why the package is smudged
so he writes a note saying i saw your
note on the door i sanitized the package
have a great day
he didn't expect anything from that she
saw the video of this kind
fedex driver and thought to herself wow
he went the extra mile took the extra
step to do this for my family
and her husband was the one who said you
should put that out on social media
maybe he'll get a raise or fedex will do
something nice for this driver
and she put it on social media it went
viral
fedex certainly you know saw that uh
justin bradshaw by the way is the fedex
driver
and as it turns out justin has a little
girl that when she was born was a
preemie and they had to take care of her
and they were worried about her so
his backstory sort of reflects upon you
know why he was doing what he was doing
so that's the story of carrie blasey and
her daughter emma
and the wonderful fedex driver justin
who did a kind thing
that deserves all of our attention then
that's why i started the book with that
chapter
yeah and it's interesting because it's
like sort of at face value what he did
wasn't that extraordinary except i think
what people have realized in this past
year
is that it is these little things that
are becoming sort of extraordinary as we
socially distance and we don't hug
people anymore and
you wear a mask and sunglasses and a hat
and then people don't even see your face
that these little things was that like a
theme for you that little things have
somehow become bigger
yes they're definitely the little things
in there like buying someone's coffee in
line and them doing it for the next
person and someone buying a coffee for
you can change
someone's day it's that simple but i
also talked about bigger movements
for instance my husband's friend ray
well he was my friend too
ray pfeiffer fdny um he was there um
after the twin towers fell yeah this is
the one that i wanted to ask you about
yeah
digging for his friends um for months uh
in toxic um a toxic
stew that we now know uh was so bad that
it caused 9 11 related illnesses
rey got very sick with cancer um
and he was just one of those guys that
would walk into a room and you just
would grab it
we call him ray of light we called him
the mayor because he would walk into a
room and he would gravitate
towards rey he would do anything for you
you know shirt off his back kind of guy
so he got sick with 911 related cancer
because he dug
uh for months trying to find his fellow
firefighters that you know their
families wanted to at least find some
remains
so he spent the rest of his days
after he was diagnosed making sure that
other first responders
would never have to worry about health
care if they were diagnosed like him
with 9 11 related illness
so ray ray we screamed as
loud as he could he went to capitol hill
he banged on congress doris
chuck schumer you know like listen
i'm dying of cancer i want to make sure
my brothers and sisters
have health care so that their families
don't have to worry because it's you
know
if their bills are high um
and so you know he's no longer with us
but
i i call he was making sunshine for his
his friends and his fellow firefighters
and his fellow first responders like my
husband
i know that if my husband ever got sick
rey would take care of him and he would
take care of our family so that was an
important story for me to tell and know
what when i think about my
fight right now with with the governor i
think of ray pfeiffer
because he did everything he could to
raise awareness
for good you know it's interesting
because when i was reading the story
about ray i was in new york also during
9 11 as i said i'm from long island but
i lived in manhattan on the upper east
during 9 11. and i remember about two
weeks after 9 11 when people finally
started even just leaving their houses
again because we were all glued to the
television and
also the smell out there and everything
else i remember i was on a
basketball court i went to play
basketball by gracie mansion i was like
i've got to get out of the house i just
like i can't
stay in my house anymore and i was
playing basketball with just a couple of
random guys and somebody elbowed one guy
and they got into each other's face and
they were about to hit each other like
you could i've seen this a million times
it was about to happen
and they both started crying at the
exact same time
both started crying like i'm getting
chills up my spine as i'm telling you
this
and so i was thinking about that when i
was reading this because it's like
those little moments of of humanity
that that is the important stuff and
it's sort of like we could use a little
more of that
i hate to say it but that sort of post
911 like yeah we all kind of are in this
together whether you like it or not
i agree i hope we can get there i i
don't know that we can right now
i feel like people are angry and they're
rightfully angry dave i mean we've been
trapped in our homes it depends on where
you live obviously but here in new york
i mean people still
can't see their loved ones in nursing
homes people have lost their businesses
and their
livelihoods i mean it's it this is tough
i hope we can get to a point where we
can
you know smile at each other again and
but having said that
i do see those pieces of humanity you
know what we went
through with our family i mean from
the firefighter down the street that
brought us a meal
you know just dropped it on our doorstep
to all of the prayer cards and prayers
that we got from other people
our church obviously you know open
opened their arms there were parishes
all over
new york that said that they were going
to honor my husband's family so
it's there and like i say in the book
sometimes you just have to really look
for it
because if you're not open to it and you
don't open your heart to it then
it might not come to you so i think that
maybe that's what we have to do is we
have to look for it
yeah so i don't want you to give away
the the entire book in this interview
but can you give me one more that maybe
was like sort of unexpected or maybe it
went in a direction that you didn't
think when you sat down with someone
something like that
you know let's see that that's that's a
good one i'm gonna think about that for
a moment
um you can go to the source if you need
it
i know let me take a look you know
there's so many of them
um well actually while you're looking
i'll mention something else so you can
look for a second but one of the things
that i really liked and i will hold the
book up for a second
is that i like that you put the photos
in here too because
you don't see that in books that much
anymore i feel like photos always used
to be in books and you don't really see
it anymore
but when you just see these are these
are just regular people
young girl you know the the 911 the
you know just guys on the street people
with glamour shots you're like oh
it reminds you that you know we're all
just human that's all it is
it's true i'm glad you said that because
i really fought hard to make sure that
their pictures were in the book you know
you
you know how you read a book and you you
exp you know you you
have a visual of what you think the
person looks like but that it's always
kind of cool to actually see what they
really look like
so i'm going to talk about seth stewart
uh the fellow that goes around on
valentine's day and gives roses to
people
um the reason i pick him is because you
know a few years ago
on february 14th valentine's day he
him and his buddies thought to
themselves you know
valentine's day is important for people
that have you know a girlfriend or
boyfriend or
or significant other you know they know
that they're going to get something but
what about
valentine's day for people who aren't
expecting a delivery at the door
so what he wanted to do was give roses
to people
that don't have their significant other
or a loved one in their life so he
prompted people by a social media to
nominate people to get a rose
and so he would go to these you know
these
residences where there were widows or
people who were having a really tough
time um
and and so this this became sort of you
know a a movement i guess
um and he was every year it was getting
bigger and bigger and bigger
and so when i talked to him he was such
a wonderful guy i love
chatting with him and he just had this
great sense of humor and
you know i asked him i'm like so you
have a girlfriend how does she feel
about this you know you going to give
roses to everybody and and he said well
you know she
she thinks it's great i said well of
course she does because you're doing
something important and his point was
i'm not giving roses to like you know
women
who i want to date i'm giving roses to
people who aren't expecting something
that they've had some kind of loss in
their life where they
they have lost somebody and maybe
they're not having a good day and just
a delivery of a rose can change their
you know their outlook and you can you
know
he sent me um notes that people wrote
afterwards about how important that one
gesture was
and then when i talked to seth he told
me something about himself he too
uh was diagnosed with diabetes and he
talked about his struggle
and how at one point he he got to the
point where he didn't want to live
anymore
and he told me this story and it just
you know it made my heart break
but the point was is that he was he's so
glad that he
wanted to stay alive and do this for
other people
and how it's important that when we go
through
challenges we realize that coming out of
those challenges we can be
better people we can do things to better
ourselves be better human beings
and so that just struck me because i
never thought about
him telling me this backstory to his
life but it was important because it
kind of gives you an
inside to where this guy is coming from
where his heart is and and you know his
background about how he
really truly wants to do good things for
other people to change their day
well janice i think your story is
basically proof that you're making your
own sunshine and
in a year that was was pretty bizarre um
you are welcome back anytime especially
if you want to talk about cuomo
and don't get and and don't get me
started on this newsome guy i'm i'm on
my own little
adventure with him so we're we're
definitely in this fight together
uh so i thank you i i hope i can see you
in long island sometime or you're always
welcome to come out here to la
megan knows my husband makes a pretty
pretty good chicken parm
can i tell you that i was so jealous
when she told me about her evening
there is no way she is going back to la
without
me and tow so that we can get together
you guys are always welcome to our home
uh and i thank you this was a wonderful
interview and and you know thank you for
your support and your kindness
and you my friend are also spreading
sunshine
there you go all right thanks a lot
welcome if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell